I want to talk to you about have tagged
at your party because this is something
that you invented quite a while ago that
I think is perfect for the time we're in
right now describe to have to get your
party it's basically me as the burning
log on the TV screen when I was touring
years ago I was missing so many friends
parties and I was pretty bummed out
about that and I thought oh might be
funny to send a video of myself just in
my hotel room and they can put it on the
TV like I'm there and then I thought
well maybe that would be a good idea to
sell to my fan base and so it actually
came out a decade ago I think on my
first album good one and and my wife
mentioned maybe I should let people know
that it's out there if you're alone and
you're ready to party I am going to be
right by your side in your house we
don't even have to socially distance
each other from each other it's perfect
for right now it is the you came up with
this quite a while ago but ladies and
gentlemen if you want TIG Notaro
at your party and let's say you're
having a zoom party and like 10 people
are there oh you and you want TIG one of
the funniest people I know to be at your
party this is a way to do that we have a
clip here oh and I believe this is you
it's a clip from have to get your party
can you tell us anything about this clip
um yeah I'm just standing there just
standing there yeah let's take a look at
this clip from have to get your party
Wow that was fantastic
um you know what I wasn't watching
really here in an empty room with
nothing else to do and I couldn't hold
your attention first it was it yeah you
couldn't hold your attention next but
that's the worst
now can't you think that have to get
your party is gonna blow up now people
if I could buy stock and have ticket
your party mm-hmm I had a choice right
now between buying stock in have ticket
your party or Charmin toilet paper I
would go all-in on have to get your
party thank you you're a smart man
I am I'm a very wise investor as you can
see valuable objects in the world behind
me um Conan I have to go you just made
me look like a fool go to TIG Notaro
calm and for $5.00 I've got five
buckaroos five bummed five bones five
bones have TIG join you for a party in
your home during this time of social
distancing this is the perfect moment
for have ting at your party take thank
you so much for joining me
Thank You Conan you're my favorite
comedian who looks exactly like Tom
Cruise I appreciate that so much
please stay hunkered and safe because
and I will I will but I hope this again
as America needs me we is that what you
were gonna say no no of course not
I was just gonna say I hope I was gonna
say I hope to see you blush thank you
very much TIG stay sane
okay you too sir bye bye I bow to you I
thank Stig thanks Conan five bones my
bones awkward pause